mango sorry welcome to this video i'm a
beast but not me but that that guy yeah
opposite me Jesse our cone is an idiot I
cannot tell you who that is maybe you
can enlighten me okay I'm just playing
them closed room will I do my line again
here i can count it it's like a bad
habit i know but so my results are not
that bad and it's and with it
yeah that I don't know how often i
played this it's too often that's that's
sure that's for sure but anyway a 5 that
is the line that mr. Naidu I played
against me in the Dutch league and it
proved to be pretty good okay I probably
start with f 6 now that's some unusual
regrouping night we three here yeah i
will put nights on f7 at g7 as i always
do and then that's one very clear point
of it I'm quick I can do this quickly
shall I try I can try something else
here push up quickly to h6 okay I'm
trying this that's an alternate an
alternative maneuver push-up f8 bishop
age 6 activating that bishop he's still
not doing anything on the queenside
interestingly enough not playing a 5 not
and not taking
here we go I've managed to activate this
small victories there and this is really
the case yes small victories but yes i
recently had this kind of thing and I've
got sure what did i do actually did I
take only 3 or not probably not I can
also and let him take maybe this son can
I do this like I know him a little bit
with that pin it's not a bad idea
believe okay something like f5 and more
voices this is really really aggressive
in comparison to what I usually do in
this kind of opening maybe it's an idea
mi5 takes everything on light of 6
come on I think gets interesting let's
do that getting pretty active all of a
sudden I mean okay work ahead it was
just about whatever sorry I was just
about to say that this is in fact a
possibility okay um what now yeah I mean
age six looks normal but yeah I think I
should do that yeah I can now take one
take a couple of times on III TX takes
f4 and to try to and try to win that
poets and that's a bit weird chick
stinks oh man ok let's go away form chat
King g7 that point is exposed however I
have some other problems of course it's
not all all great if i take it route 87
is already very annoying so I'm probably
have to do this important points that is
not only to was really bad stop doing
anything hmm I'm out for Luke h5 and
grabbing g5
hmm yeah I think he has to go Bishop a
foreign to open up the FL sooner or
later he has to do it
yeah okay 897 I mean it's kind of weird
I i have a good i have it is it good
yeah i think it's a good position I have
a good position again with my wacky line
but difficult for him to keep that pawn
on d5 yes his artful p should be six but
i can go back to e8 it's not a big deal
really i'm not sure if i should have
played 97 in the first place now that i
think of it i didn't really I didn't
need to do that really didn't ok
k g for now and not g5 at the end it's
not clear that this really does does
this help okay
interesting with a jacket is getting
kind of active so maybe not such a great
idea to take
I don't see a clear way to win this even
though it's certainly nice with that
porn but I don't really see how to win
time morning
cannot instead night still we called him
difficult to get active ha ha coughing
even draw here I think he's active
enough gain draw yeah i thought we
should have won that somehow I think I
bet they're at least I think that I
should have but I couldn't really figure
it out so let's let's check but I really
didn't see any any way forward so I
think a draw wasn't it wasn't so bad
I've killed myself so often yeah trying
to win positions when that wasn't really
really old ok this this f5 yeah it looks
interesting he went with this yeah and
wrote here the engine wants to go 97 @
h5 which isn't bad idea I like this but
ok
mmm the compounds to check and play this
this is a better version and this is a
better version of the game because now
if I do this right then now this is a
much bigger problem because now I
couldn't take with the bishop on behalf
interesting you did this and I took
cheeks chat leagues chains yeah I mean
this isn't is better I mean in winning
this pawn ultimately so what was my
mistake okay here the engine wants to do
look aged three yeah maybe I was playing
to have to technical anyway I saw how i
get the pawn and I grabbed it a nudge if
I 95 strongly of course and now when you
see this easier the text sorry a text f3
and King f2 it's not really a move yeah
it's it's better but ok let's let's see
how am I can I win this somehow
I need to get G phone which i didn't
manage in the game this this g5 this G
59 f 2 yeah the engine is giving this I
mean I saw the idea but I felt it is
somewhat risky and this and this is what
the computer wants to do 495 and
grabbing this but I thought you would
win the pawn that it's not really
relevant I guess Jack I can do this I
know we've got seven yeah the pawn is
very very dangerous and if he goes back
if he goes back let's say check this i
will take here now the night only for
would always keep that covered yeah yeah
okay the beep on is too far away okay so
that was the opportunity that I had here
again I can play G form and now in fact
it is really it is really a difficult to
do anything yeah he's got he's got
enough activity now so I missed that
that opportunity and I had time on the
clock that wasn't good ah ok thanks for
watching